[Music]  lindy  this is not a cure the only way we're  gonna make progress  this cutting-edge avant-garde treat  i've got this condition it makes me snap  like tourette's just tiny bit more  intense i've upped the voltage  but there's only so much that the human  body can take  hello this is detective vickers sounds  like your guy was involved in some  pretty sketchy business  i'm gonna find you did this  if you go down that path you are never  ever going to get better  deal with her you spent years being  forced to repress your anger  but now you have seen how powerful you  can be when you embrace your  age oh seriously you're gonna make me go  through the whole  face dumping bone breaking making a mess  routine  okay fine  you're gonna get somebody killed i'm  trying to help you uh-huh  how's that going for you  what is it about gross old men always  underestimating women  are you really that stupid you know what  i think i am  exactly that stupid  [Applause]  [Music]  you